[Música]
después del estallido de la revolución
francesa en
1789 Europa quedó sumida en el caos Los
Monarcas de países vecinos temían
compartir el destino de Luis x y
atacaron a la nueva República mientras
Francia se desangraba por el extremismo
y la desconfianza entre bandos en medio
de todo este conflicto una figura
poderosa ASUME el en Francia pero salvó
la revolución o la
destruyó orden Quién es el demandado hoy
no veo a
nadie su señoría es Napoleón Bonaparte
el tirano que invadió casi toda Europa
para compensar su inseguridad personal
debido a su baja
estatura en realidad Napoleón tenía la
altura promedio del momento la idea de
su baja estatura Viene solo de la
propaganda de guerra británica y no era
un tirano protegía a la joven República
de ser aplastada por las monarquías
europeas derrocando a su gobierno y
tomando el poder para
Sí su señoría como joven y exitoso
oficial militar Napoleón apoyaba
completamente la revolución francesa y
sus ideales de libertad igualdad y
fraternidad pero los revolucionarios no
pudieron asumir un verdadero liderazgo
robespierre y los jacobinos que llegaron
primero al poder desataron un reino de
terror en la población con su extremismo
anticatólico y las ejecuciones continuas
de todo el que discrepar con
ellos el directorio que los reemplazó
era una oligarquía inestable e
incompetente necesitaban un líder fuerte
que pudiera gobernar con prudencia y
Justicia Francia pasó por esa Revolución
y terminó teniendo otro gobernante
todopoderoso no exactamente los nuevos
poderes de Napoleón se derivaron de la
constitución aprobada por una votación
Popular en el consulado Ah la
Constitución fue casi dictada a punta de
pistola en un golpe militar y el público
solo aceptó al tirano porque estaba
cansado de la constante Guerra Civil sea
como fuere Napoleón introdujo una nueva
constitución y un código legal que
mantienen intactos algunos de los logros
más importantes de la Revolución la
libertad religiosa La abolición de los
privilegios hereditarios y la igualdad
ante la ley para todos hombres todos los
hombres sí privó a las mujeres de los
derechos que la revolución les había
dado y reinstaurar en las colonias
francesas Haití todavía hoy se está
recuperando de las consecuencias Qué
clase de igualdad es esa la única que
podía haber en esa época y estaba
incluso muy por delante de los vecinos
de Francia hablando de vecinos Qué pasó
con las invasiones muy buena pregunta
señoría A qué invasiones nos referimos
fueron los imperios vecinos qui quienes
habían invadido Francia tratando de
restaurar la monarquía y evitar la
propagación de la libertad por Europa
dos veces antes de la Asunción de
Napoleón Después de defender a Francia
como soldado y general en esas guerras
él sabía que la mejor defensa es un buen
ataque un ataque contra todo el
continente en 1802 se aseguró la paz y
otras potencias europeas reconocieron el
nuevo régimen Francés pero Bonaparte no
podía descansar Hasta tener el control
de todo el continente y él solo sabía a
luchar trató de implementar un bloqueo a
Gran Bretaña a escala europea invadió
todo país que no cumpliera y lanzó más
guerras para aferrarse a sus victorias y
cuál fue el resultado millones de
muertos en todo el continente y un orden
internacional destruido se le olvidó la
otra consecuencia la propagación de los
ideales de democracia y Libertad en toda
Europa el continente se reformó gracias
a Napoleón pasó de un mosaico caótico de
territorios feudales y religiosos a
Estados na seculares eficientes modernos
donde las personas detentaron más poder
y derechos que nunca
antes hay que agradecerle también el
ascenso del nacionalismo y el aumento
del tamaño de los ejércitos se puede ver
lo bien que resultó un siglo más tarde
Cómo sería la historia Europea de no
haber sido por
Napoleón inconcebible
el ímpetu imparable de Napoleón moriría
en las nieves del Invierno ruso junto
con la mayor parte de su ejército pero
incluso después de haber sido destituido
y exiliado se negó a darse por vencido
escapó de prisión y lanzó un Audaz
intento de restaurar su imperio antes de
ser Derrotado por segunda y última
vez Bonaparte fue un gobernante lleno de
contradicciones que defendía una
Revolución popular imponiendo una
dictadura absoluta y difundía ideales
liberales mediante guerras imperiales y
aunque nunca alcanzó su sueño de conqu
estar Europa sin duda dejó su huella
allí para bien o para
mal siga poniendo en tela de juicio a
figuras controversiales con este video
sobre Cleopatra sigue siendo una de las
mujeres más notorias de la historia pero
era solo una exitosa seductora o era una
gran gobernante por derecho propio es
usted quien decide